J'ai 18 minutes pour vous raconter ce qui s'est passé
depuis les six derniers millions d'années.
Bien.
Nous avons parcouru un long chemin,
ici en Afrique, et avons convergé dans cette région d'Afrique,
un endroit où s'est passé 90% de notre évolution.
Je ne dis pas cela parce que je suis Africain,
mais parce que c'est en Afrique que l'on trouve les traces les plus anciennes
des ancêtres humains, des traces de bipédisme,
et même les premières technologies sous forme d'outils en pierre.
Nous sommes donc tous Africains et bienvenue chez vous.
Bien.
Je suis un paléoanthropologue et mon travail consiste à définir
la place de l'homme dans la nature et à explorer ce qui fait de nous des humains,
et aujourd'hui je me servirai de Selam, l'enfant le plus ancien jamais découvert,
pour vous raconter une histoire qui nous concerne tous.
Selam est le squelette le plus complet que nous ayons d'une enfant de trois ans
qui a vécu et est morte il y a 3,3 millions d'années.
Elle appartient à l'espèce Australopithèque afarensis.
Vous n'avez pas besoin de retenir cela.
Elle fait partie de la même espèce que Lucy, et a été découverte par mon équipe
en décembre 2000 dans une zone qui s'appelle Dikika.
Elle est située au Nord-Est de l'Ethiopie.
Selam veut dire "paix" dans beaucoup de langues éthiopiennes.
Nous utilisons ce nom pour célébrer la paix dans la région et sur la planète.
Le fait qu'elle ait fait la couverture de tous ces magazines très connus
vous donne déjà une idée de son importance, je pense.
Après avoir été invité par TED j'ai creusé un peu,
parce que c'est ce que nous faisons, pour mieux connaître mon hôte.
On ne se jette pas comme ça sur une invitation.
Et j'ai appris que la première technologie est apparue
sous forme d'outils en pierre il y a 2,6 millions d'années.
Les premières preuves de divertissement proviennent de flûtes vieilles de 35,000 ans.
Et les premières traces de design viennent de perles vieilles de 75,000 ans.
Vous pouvez faire la même chose avec vos gènes et rechercher leurs ancêtres en remontant dans le temps.
Et puis l'analyse des humains et des chimpanzés vivants
nous montre aujourd'hui que la divergence s'est produite il y a environ sept millions d'années,
et que ces deux espèces ont en commun plus de 98% de leur matériel génétique.
Je pense que savoir cela nous donne un contexte très utile
pour nous aider à penser à nos ancètres.
Cependant, cette analyse ne nous informe que sur
le début et la fin, et ne nous dit rien
sur ce qui s'est passé à mi-chemin.
Notre travail à nous les paléoanthropologues est de trouver des preuves tangibles,
des fossiles, pour combler ce vide
et voir les différentes étapes du développement.
Parce que c'est seulement lorsque vous faites cela que vous pouvez discuter de...
(Rires)
C'est seulement lorsque vous faites cela que vous pouvez discuter
de ce à quoi nous ressemblions et de la manière dont nous nous comportions à différentes époques,
et comment ces préférences, aspects et comportements ont évolué au cours du temps,
ce qui vous donne ensuite accès
à l'exploration des mécanismes biologiques
et des forces responsables de ce changement graduel
qui ont fait de nous ce que nous sommes aujourd'hui.
Mais trouver des preuves tangibles est une tâche très difficile.
Il faut une approche scientifique systématique,
qui va vous emmener dans des endroits isolés, très chauds, hostiles et souvent inaccessibles.
Pour vous donner un exemple, lorsque je suis allé à Dikika,
là où Selam à été trouvée en 99, à environ 500 kilomètres
d'Addis Abeba, la capitale de l'Ethiopie,
cela ne nous a pris que sept heures pour faire les premiers 470 kilomètres,
mais il nous a fallu quatre bonnes heures pour parcourir les derniers trente kilomètres.
Avec l'aide des populations locales et à l'aide de simples pelles et de pioches, j'ai tracé mon chemin.
J'ai été la première personne qui a, de fait, conduit une voiture jusqu'à cet endroit.
Quand vous arrivez là-bas, voici ce que vous voyez,
et l'immensité de l'endroit vous donne une impression d' impuissance et de vulnérabilité.
Une fois que vous êtes là, la vraie question qui se pose est par où commencer.
(Rires)
Et pendant des années, vous ne trouvez rien.
Lorsque je me rends à des endroits comme celui-ci, sur ces sites paléontologiques,
c'est comme d'aller dans une réserve animale, une réserve d'animaux disparus.
Mais ce que vous y trouvez ce ne sont pas des restes humains,
comme ceux de Selam et de Lucy, au quotidien.
Vous trouvez des éléphants, des rhinocéros, des singes, des cochons, etc.
Vous pourriez demander comment ces grands mammifères ont fait pour
vivre dans cet environnement désertique?
Bien sûr il ne le peuvent pas, mais je vous dis tout de suite
que l'environnement et la capacité de cette région
à supporter la vie était complètement différente de ce que nous avons aujourd'hui.
Ceci peut nous donner une leçon très importante sur l'environnement.
Donc, une fois que l'on est arrivé là, c'est une réserve, comme je l'ai dit -- une réserve d'animaux éteints.
Et nos ancêtres vivaient dans cette réserve animale,
mais n'en représentaient qu'une minorité. Ils ne réussisaient pas aussi bien
et n'étaient pas aussi répandus que l'Homo sapiens que nous sommes.
Pour vous donner un exemple, une anecdote sur leur rareté,
j'allais à cet endroit chaque année et je travaillais sur le terrain,
et les assistants, bien sûr, m'aidaient à faire les fouilles.
Ils trouvaient un os et me disaient: "voilà ce que vous cherchez".
Je répondais: "Non, c'est un éléphant".
Puis un autre -- "C'est un singe", "c'est un cochon", etc.
Alors un de mes assistants, qui n'est jamais allé à l'école, m'a dit: "Ecoute, Zeray.
Soit tu ne sais pas ce que tu cherches,
soit tu ne cherches pas au bon endroit".
(Rires)
Et j'ai demandé: "Pourquoi?". "Parce qu'il y avait des éléphants et des lions,
et les gens ont eu peur et sont allés ailleurs.
Allons ailleurs".
Il était très fatigué, et c'est vraiment fatigant.
C'est après ce travail dur et de nombreuses années frustrantes que nous avons trouvé Selam,
et vous voyez ici la figure recouverte de grès.
Là on voit la colonne vertébrale
ainsi que l'ensemble du torse pris dans un bloc de grès,
parce qu'elle était enterrée près d'une rivière.
Ce que vous voyez ici n'a l'air de rien,
mais contient en fait une quantité incroyable d'informations scientifiques
qui nous aident à étudier ce qui constitue notre humanité.
C'est le plus ancien et le plus complet ancêtre humain juvénile
jamais trouvé dans l'histoire de la paléoanthropologie --
un témoin incroyable de notre longue, longue histoire.
Il y avait ces trois personnes plus moi et c'est moi qui prends les photos,
c'est pourquoi je ne suis pas dessus.
Que ressentiriez-vous à ma place, avec quelque chose d'extraordinaire entre vos mains,
et vous êtes au beau milieu de nulle part?
Je ressentais un bonheur profond et calme et de l'excitation,
avec en plus un sentiment énorme de responsabilité,
pour être sûr que tout était bien protégé.
Voici un gros plan du fossile après cinq années de nettoyage,
de préparation et de description --ce qui a été très long.
j'ai du sortir les os du bloc de grès
que je vous ai montré dans la dispositive précédente.
Cela a pris cinq ans.
D'une certaine manière, c'est comme une seconde naissance pour cette enfant après 3,3 million d'années,
mais l'accouchement a été très long.
Et le voici à taille normale -- c'est un tout petit os.
Au milieu se trouve le ministre du tourisme éthiopien,
venu rendre visite au musée national d'Ethiopie au moment où j'y travaillais.
Vous me voyez inquiet, essayant de protéger mon enfant,
parce vous ne confiez ce genre d'enfant à personne,
même pas à un ministre.
Alors une fois que vous avez fait cela, l'étape d'après consiste à déterminer de quoi il s'agit.
(Rires)
Une fois cela fait, il a été possible de faire des comparaisons.
Nous avons pu déterminer qu'elle appartenait
à la famille humaine parce que les jambes, le pied,
et quelques autres traits montraient clairement qu'elle était bipède,
et le bipédisme est une caractéristique majeure de l'humanité.
De plus, si vous comparez le crâne
à celui d'un chimpanzé d'âge similaire et au petit George Bush ici,
vous voyez que vous avez un front vertical,
et vous voyez que chez les humains, à cause du développement
du cortex pré-frontal, qui s'appelle --
vous ne voyez pas cela chez les chimpanzés,
et vous ne voyez pas non plus ces canines saillantes.
Elle fait donc partie de nos ancêtres, mais au-delà de cela, bien sûr,
vous faites une analyse détaillée et nous savons maintenant
qu'elle fait partie de la même espèce que Lucy,
connue sous le nom d'Australopithèque afarensis.
La question brûlante d'après est de déterminer s'il s'agit d'une fille ou d'un garçon,
et à quel âge elle est morte.
Vous pouvez déterminer le genre d'un individu
en vous basant sur la taille des dents.
Comment?
Vous savez,chez les primates, il y a un phénomène
appelé dimorphisme sexuel, ce qui veut tout simplement dire
que les mâles sont plus grands que les femelles et ont de plus grandes dents
qu'elles.
Mais pour déterminer cela, vous devez voir la dentition permanente,
que vous ne voyez pas parce que ce qui est apparent ici
ce sont les dents de lait.
Mais en utilisant la technologie du CT scan (tomodensitimétrie axiale) ,
que l'on utilise habituellement en médecine,
vous pouvez explorer la bouche et faire émerger cette magnifique image
qui vous montre à la fois les dents de lait ici
et les dents définitives encore en croissance, là.
Lorsque vous mesurez ces dents,
il est apparu clairement que c'était une fille
avec de toutes petites canines.
Pour déterminer à quel âge elle est morte,
vous faites une estimation basées sur le temps qu'il faut
à ces dents de lait pour sortir et la réponse a été trois ans.
Cette fillette est donc morte aux environs de trois ans,
il y a 3,3 millions d'années.
Avec ces informations en main, la grande question est --
qu'est-ce que l'on -- qu'est-ce qu'elle nous dit?
Pour répondre à cette question, nous pouvons en poser une autre --
que savons-nous en fait sur nos ancêtres?
Nous voulons savoir à quoi ils ressemblaient, comment ils se comportaient,
comment ils marchaient,
et comment ils vivaient et grandissaient.
Parmi les réponses que nous donne ce squelette
on trouve -- d'abord ce squelette montre
pour la première fois à quoi ressemblaient les jeunes enfants il y a plus de trois million d'années.
Deuxièmement, il nous dit qu'elle était bipède,
mais avec des adaptations pour monter aux arbres.
Encore plus intéressant,
il nous montre que le cerveau de cette enfant était encore en croissance.
A trois ans, si votre cerveau est encore en train de se former,
c'est un comportement humain.
Chez les chimpanzés, à trois ans, le cerveau est formé à 90%.
C'est ce qui leur permet de s'adapter à leur environnement
très facilement après la naissance -- plus rapidement que nous en tous les cas.
Chez les humains, le cerveau continue à grandir.
C'est pour cela que nous avons besoin des soins de nos parents.
Mais soins veut aussi dire apprentissage.
Vous passez plus de temps avec vos parents.
C'est très caractéristique des humains et cela s'appelle l'enfance,
qui est cette période étendue de dépendance des enfants humains
par rapport à leur famille ou leurs parents.
Le cerveau en formation de cet individu
nous montre donc que l'enfance, qui demande
une organisation sociale incroyable,
une organisation sociale très complexe,
est apparue il y a plus de trois millions d'années.
En se situant aux prémices de notre histoire,
Selam nous réunit tous et nous montre d'une manière unique
ce qui fait de nous des humains.
Mais tout n'était pas humain et je vais vous donner
un exemple très excitant.
Cela s'appelle l'os hyoïde. C'est un os qui se situe juste ici.
Il soutient notre langue par derrière.
D'une certaine manière c'est la caisse de résonance de votre voix.
Il détermine le type de voix que vous produisez.
Nous n'avions pas cet os dans nos archives de fossiles,
mais nous l'avons dans ce squelette.
Quand nous avons analysé cet os, il était clair
qu'il avait une apparence très similaire à celui des chimpanzés.
Si vous aviez été là il y a 3,3 million d'années,
pour entendre cette fillette appeler sa mère,
elle aurait produit des sons plus proches du chimpanzé que de l'humain.
Peut-être que vous vous demandez: "Alors vous voyez ce trait simiesque, ce trait humain, ce trait simiesque.
Qu'est-ce que cela nous apprend?".
Vous savez, c'est très excitant pour nous,
parce que cela démontre que les choses changeaient lentement et progressivement,
et que l'évolution est cours.
Pour résumer l'importance de ce fossile,
nous pouvons dire la chose suivante.
Jusqu'à maintenant la connaissance que nous avions de nos ancêtres
provenait essentiellement d'individus adultes
parce que nous n'avions pas de fossiles de bébés.
Ils ne se conservent pas bien, comme vous le savez.
La connaissance que nous avions de nos ancêtres,
de leur apparence, leur comportement,
était biaisée en faveur des adultes.
Imaginez quelqu'un qui vienne de Mars
et son boulot est de faire un rapport sur le type de personnes
qui occupent notre planète Terre, et vous cachez tous les bébés,
les enfants, et il retourne chez lui et fait son rapport.
Pouvez-vous imaginer à quel point son rapport serait biaisé?
C'est un peu ce que nous faisions jusqu'à présent
en l'absence de fossile d'enfants,
et je pense que ce nouveau fossile résoud ce problème.
Finalement, la question la plus importante est de savoir
ce que nous apprennent vraiment des spécimens comme celui-ci
et ce que nous apprend notre passé de façon générale?
Bien sur, en plus d'extraire cette quantité énorme
d'information scientifique sur ce qui constitue notre humanité,
vous savez, les nombreux ancêtres humains qui ont existé
au cours des six derniers millions d'années -- et il y en a plus de 10 --
ils n'avaient pas la connaissance, la technologie et la sophistication
que nous les Homo sapiens avons aujourd'hui.
Mais si cette espèce, cette ancienne espèce,
pouvait voyager dans le temps et nous voir aujourd'hui,
ils seraient très fiers de ce qu'ils ont laissé en héritage,
parce qu'ils sont devenus les ancêtres de
l'espèce qui a le mieux réussi dans l'univers.
et ils n'étaient probablement pas conscients de cet héritage qu'ils nous laissaient,
mais ils se sont bien débrouillés.
La question qui se pose maintenant est, nous, les Homo sapiens
sommes en mesure de décider du futur de notre planète, et peut-être plus.
Alors la question est de savoir si nous saurons relever le défi.
Pouvons-nous vraiment mieux faire que ces ancêtres primitifs,
dotés de petits cerveaux?
Un des défis les plus pressants auquel se trouve confrontée notre espèce
aujourd'hui est l'ensemble des problèmes chroniques qui affectent l'Afrique.
Il n'est pas besoin de les lister aujourd'hui, et il y a des gens plus compétents
pour en parler.
Néanmoins, selon moi, nous avons deux options.
Une est de continuer à avoir une Afrique pauvre, malade, qui pleure --
armée -- qui continuera à dépendre des autres indéfiniment,
l'autre est de promouvoir une Afrique qui a confiance en elle,
en paix, indépendante, mais consciente de ses énormes problèmes
et de ses grandes valeurs en même temps.
Je suis partisan de la deuxième option, et je suis sûr que beaucoup d'entre vous aussi.
La clé est de promouvoir une attitude positive des Africains à l'égard de l'Afrique.
C'est parce nous les Africains nous nous concentrons --
je viens d'Ethiopie, soit dit en passant --
nous nous concentrons trop sur la façon dont nous sommes perçus
ailleurs et à l'extérieur.
Je pense qu'il faut promouvoir de manière plus positive
la perception que nous avons de nous-mêmes.
C'est ce que j'appelle africaine -- une attitude positive africaine.
Pour finir, j'aimerais dire
qu'il faut aider l'Afrique à se tenir debout et à aller de l'avant --
alors nous pourrons tous être fiers de l'héritage que nous allons laisser en tant qu'espèce.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)